the last time I spoke to you was a
mission uh red carpet in Paris you told
an amazing story about riding the Metro
with a girl noticing you I just want to
say thank you for that story because it
went everywhere but for today there are
a ton of people that have never that are
young kids that have actually never seen
any of your movies what is the movie
that you would like them to start with
and why
dead reckoning part one that's what
we're here for today I mean here we are
in Rome they could start with this film
to see and understand that this is all
real all the action's real it's
practical this movie is an epic
adventure it's it's so Lush you know
filled with practical action and amazing
locations and it's it has all the things
that I love in movies submarines that
has the desert it has you know Rome
beautiful locations in Abu Dhabi Norway
a train that we built you know action on
the train in a very engrossing story
with with really A Beautiful cast an
amazing very charismatic cast and I
think when you look at this movie it
really defines you know what I think
about Cinema and why you know because
you look at this kind of cast you look
at a brilliant ensemble cast and the
kind of story is very engrossing I will
tell you I've seen it it's the fastest
two hours and 30 minutes of the year uh
I I love this movie so much uh you have
done amazing stunts over the through
your career and I'm just curious what do
you view like the top five or top 10 of
the most the difficulty of what you've
done in terms of the nervousness of the
people around you
I don't know
well don't know I don't I don't Gage
their nervousness I don't I don't know I
you know I know I've done some Wild
Things uh I know I've done some wild
things I think you probably have a
better
better way to look at it than I am
because I'm so inside of it sure you
know when I'm doing it and I just know
you know what we try to do with these
films and actually all of my movies I've
you know I remember as a
as an audience member which I am first
and foremost and I make my as a
filmmaker I make my movies for audiences
but I always I wanted I like a wide
range of Cinema and so I've always
wanted to challenge myself in a wide
range of genres and styles to understand
each one and I'd go into it and then
study each one as I was making it and
test my abilities in that so and I try
to take everything that I've learned
my entire career and put it in the next
movement and put in the next move and
put in the next movie just in terms of
structure storytelling character
development as a producer in terms of
how I produce a film how I can better
prepare my cast my crew for for the
adventure that we're all embarking on so
that that is the things that I think
about and I'm constantly challenging
myself I'm both I'm both a student every
single day I'm constantly studying and
also a teacher because I'm constantly
having to kind of
work with people to go
this is movies for me and for us and and
and and also bring their voices into our
film the last thing for you I love IMAX
it's my favorite format maybe can you
talk just a touch on why you should see
this in IMAX I think you should see it
in any major format any big format you
know you we have we have IMAX we have
Dolby Vision you know you've got Dolby
and Dolby Vision which is you know all
of these all of these tools that we have
you know you have screen X there's and
we're actually working on that version
of the film right now and it depends on
what kind of experience they want with
the cinema we this is made for the big
screen experience it is the mix is made
for that and we spend a lot of time in
every format to ensure that it is
that it is as we're using every tool and
the toolbox to give that experience and
immersive experience for the audience
sir thank you so much for real man the
movie's incredible